i come from the roasts i come from the
roast rooms i come from the forefront
did you meet trump when you roasted him
yes you like yes was he cool this is
actually one of my favorite stories ever
and it's um uh because that guy is first
and foremost an entertainer first he was
the number one tv star in the world i
remember when this [ __ ] was happening i
was like this he's gonna [ __ ] win
because he knows how to command
attention yeah love it or hate it and
then and then the [ __ ] most genius
[ __ ] is remember one of the debates he
said i'm not coming you guys need me
more than i need you he got more
attention by not showing up than
everyone else did by showing up you know
that guy attracts attention when he's
not there like yeah you know but um did
the roast he demanded that it be in new
york which was kind of annoying because
normally it's in l.a before that i'd
done joan rivers david hasselhoff and
then i wrote for saggett pam anderson
flavor flav and um so we're shooting at
new york and uh it's all these like old
ass people it's like larry king and
[ __ ] all these idiots oh uh jerry
springer like all his friends may he
rest in peace yeah i remember i think i
started with you guys let's let's speed
this up um before larry king dies like i
think it was
and um i'm hammering him and there was
an off-limits thing every roast has an
off-limits right
uh shatner was the dead woman in the
pool
okay remember william shatner had a dead
woman his wife died in the pool drowned
something let's [ __ ] up your algorithm
uh and then pam anderson was the kid in
the pool
because a baby a kid drowned at one of
their parties at one of their parties
oh my joan rivers was her sister her uh
daughter melissa can't make fun of no
one and then hulk hogan said we couldn't
make fun of his daughter
uh and then i remember i what did i yeah
shatner's wife died in the pool oh yeah
yeah that's rough yeah yeah uh and then
yeah right and then so for um
who's this trump trump it was not even
ivanka weirdly it was melania and i just
was like i'm not cutting i mean i had
like four pages of [ __ ] milania jokes
and i was like you know because she also
did qvc at the time so i was doing jokes
it's like you know um about that and
then oh the diamond you shouldn't have
gotten uh melania is such a big diamond
ring now she knows what heart is
supposed to feel like
constantly his [ __ ] shitty uh like
real estate stuff whatever like i was
like people don't know like we're
talking making fun of his hair we're
making fun of his dick like how bad he
is at business like naming and he was
like dying laughing the whole time get
off stage and he pulls me close puts his
hand on my lower back and goes fire huh
fire fire that's good that's good
he goes um
i thought he was gonna be like mad he
was that was great television
wow
television you get to think about that
great not that was funny that was not
funny that was mean it was great it
doesn't [ __ ] matter what i think that
was great television because he looked
like he was upset and he was kind of
like playing it up i think he was kind
of like oh man
like he was sort of like whoo and then
he was like great television
like we were in on it together
it was weird because i was really coming
for him and i didn't hurt him at all any
other interaction with him um not really
he did ask for my number though no he
didn't yeah you said yesterday i don't
know he asked through like an agent and
i don't remember what i said that's a
yes so yeah i don't know if he didn't
call me or not but he didn't call me
that now do you feel a sense of
rejection that he didn't reach out
yeah
yeah yeah yeah my pussy's easy to grab
what is that by the way what is that was
there something about the grabbing by
the [ __ ] that we i didn't get what do
you mean like is that a thing that is
done what just grabbing that
what happens when monkey grab someone's
[ __ ] is that like a thing
or was that something you you guys heard
it we're like oh what is that it's just
the craziest thing to like get a girl to
come over yeah yes it's a wild thing to
do yeah that's what's great i think he
was being
i think that's what it is he was just
making great television yeah it was
making great television
making great audio yeah didn't even know
anyone was listening because you know
entertainment
when i did the roast of joan rivers i
know why you look so young here
i know no
what oh i i was like why does she look
so funny so when he steps on my punch
line you don't do anything
[Laughter]
am i co-hosting a podcast with you
already
[Laughter]
is
[Laughter]
and i said i wanted to do a joke that
said um uh for comedy you went to
elementary with her right
factory together that's fire dude
okay go
miles miles got
joan rivers has had so much plastic
surgery every year she books montreal
new
that's a good joke faces a good joke but
it was such an inside comedy joke it's
about the montreal new faces yeah the
only comics you're gonna get yeah so i
actually chickened out on that one but i
did at the time i remember i think this
was the joke that kind of was like the
one i think that everyone sort of was
like oh a woman can maybe be funny for
like a minute um which was uh this at
the time the
sorry
sorry
he's like has to make noise like just
happen you know what you're like when
the fans from the opposite team [ __ ]
hold the doodles while someone's trying
to shoot a free throw oh that's what
you're doing
i'm just listening to you i'm enjoying
everything you're saying um you're a
woman talking
it's not this is my favorite business
it's my favorite it is profitable you
made tens of millions of dollars do you
people know how rich you are do you
you're so rich thank you
do you
do you yeah do i what feel like a relief
now that you're married i feel like i
want you to finish your story
that's what i feel like oh i don't know
why i just thought you might want to
talk about yourself no i want to talk
about you i like talking about you with
joan i love doing the wrestler
um
that's hilarious right now that's great
that's great joan rivers is so old her
[ __ ] has a separate entrance for black
[ __ ]
i got i got the job writing for the
roasts on the flavor flavors i wasn't
allowed to be on it yet but i wrote a
joke that s'more ended up doing um which
was for flavor flav and the joke was
flav you look like what magic johnson
should look like right
[Laughter]
what was your first one first roast i
was on new stone rivers it was joan
rivers yes and that really i think i
remember stuff from that by the way i
also did the way i was able to get on it
uh is i had to make a tape uh when i did
a friar's club roast of steve tish
who is uh one the owner of the nyu the
giant yes a giant it was like a private
family
and i yes and i did the um uh quentin
tarantino one those remember when the
friars club
tarantino was that fun he was great and
he had a good sense of humor well that
was the likes feat yeah but you know
what he's up i was [ __ ] on some [ __ ]
man it was weinstein brett ratner like
the whole
group of people was nuts and none of
them tried to [ __ ] you i did i know
isn't that embarrassing a little bit i
know but that's how you know you were
funny i don't need mace i have this
personality
like i've never had a [ __ ] problem
wait really yeah and uh what i do for um
harvey weinstein harvey weinstein has
[ __ ] so many [ __ ] he doesn't have
the clap he has the applause that's good
that's funny and then it was like don't
laugh brett you have a standing ovation
now now did weinstein ever
holler at any of your friends weinstein
came to the comedy store one night to
see me and uh it was when tommy was
working there and this was after the
road after the rose he met me tommy
maybe explain to the people tommy i'm
sorry tommy was someone that ran the
comedy store at the time he is no longer
there um him leaving
coincided with the rise in popularity
saved to the comedy story came back yeah
yeah yeah
um black people came back it was the
whole thing yeah yeah um so uh weinstein
came in one night and uh this was after
the so he had met me at the roast and
then was like i'm gonna go see her at a
comedy club whatever and um i'm like
you're coming to a comedy club you're
the least rapey person in here um but uh
he
i was just in the [ __ ] green room at
the comedy store like um
sorry no i'm i'm too old for that
[Music]
i'd already seen three dicks today
what's another day
and so he uh came in and then i left
because you know in l.a we do three four
spots we pop around and so i left to go
to the improv or something and then
tommy called me was like hey harvey
weinstein's here like you gotta gotta
like come and i remember being like i
have a spot like what am i gonna do and
then i didn't go back which this is how
[ __ ] dumb i was i was like i don't
want him to see me in that lighting like
whatever good just happened if he's
gonna hire me
that's that's the best i can do like i'm
not gonna let him see me look like steve
buscemi in the [ __ ] shadows um at the
comedy store so i just never went back
you were worried about the
the way you looked in the lighting the
comedy store lighting everyone looks
like steve buscemi
okay
do you have do you have a dysmorphia
about the way you look do you think
you think maybe a little i mean being
friends with you doesn't help
i always say how beautiful you are
i roll the tape i do
i don't know i it was i know it's more
like it just was like there's i can only
lose by seeing him again you know it's
like you've seen my world that's smart
you've seen what i can do like i'm not
gonna go ruin it with my [ __ ]
personality yeah and eye bags you know
which is in my brain are you
are you the most beautiful comic ever
um it's a valid question if you look at
other comments
i mean
i just thought of it like who is um like
come on we can do stand-up
yes he does an insult and a compliment
that's great